Josh lead as born and raised in Columbia
South Carolina people say oh that must
have been odd but I mean a lot of us are
from South Carolina and doesn't seem
very strange to me how has it affected
how I see the world I might have more of
estates right attitude than a lot of
people from other places you know I'm a
bit more individual rights than other
people so I don't know that's all I got
you know I always knew I wanted to write
I always wanted to write I thought I
would be a poet but i knew i wanted to
write they weren't they didn't push me
in any particular direction I think my
mother would been happier if I'd become
a lawyer or something you know I don't
know it's sort of clichéd they have a
funny rabbi you know every rabbi thinks
he's pretty hilarious or early to do
nowadays and in the old days I think
they thought they were pretty serious I
you know I don't know how I could wax
philosophical and say well there's you
know comedy and religion are about some
sort of aspiration is something higher
or do you know to elevate us and what we
laugh you know our souls become bigger
but i don't think so i think i think
rabbis are smart people and i think
smart people tend to be funny so maybe
that's the connection by the way I
should have been drinking coffee but I
don't is there any connection whatsoever
you know I think there must be some
connection between religion and comedy
because while because the people i know
in comedy are either pretty religious or
in ms minority or they're a swing the
other way completely in our rapidly
atheistic so maybe there's some
emotional switch that gets clicked on
either way the Lampoon you know I don't
I think it obviously goes in ways i know
the writers it's creating right now i
think they're all good if just a hot
look you're at Harvard so you might go
through a pretty good pool to choose
from and it's got this nice building and
the sort of sweet setup and you know so
it becomes very attractive and then it's
got this history so you know it becomes
very easy to attract sort of talented
writers and then you know when you're
there you sort of want to live up to the
the people who've been there before I
mean that said actually putting out the
magazine not really always that funny
but the there is a competitive nature
within the you know people on the
magazine itself where you're always sort
of trying to better each other and
one-up each other so you know it's all
those Rams butting their heads
eventually makes you stronger in my
freshman year yeah yeah I hadn't heard
of it before I got there and then I
remember walking around the campus and
seeing this really cool building and
that's ago I'd like to go in there and
it turned out that Lampoon yeah you know
my foot I you know they invite you in to
see if you want to compete to join and
they give you beer and that was nice so
it's just sitting around drinking beer
like they tell you stuff and then sort
of every event after that was a social
opportunity was drinking cocktails or
beer and getting your writing critiqued
that's all good